[Music]
luke is with us luke is in
kansas city hi luke what's up
hey guys good afternoon thanks for
taking my call sure how can i help
so i travel through the midwest selling
building materials in four states
missouri kansas iowa nebraska
i drive my own vehicle and the company
gives me a vehicle reimbursement program
as you can imagine i drive about a lot
of miles about 40 000 a year and
certainly have racked up the miles on my
personal vehicle
my question is
should i
buy a second vehicle exclusive to
work travel only
and separate the two since they do give
me so much money a month
well the the misnomer is that the money
that you get for vehicle reimbursement
all has to be spent necessarily on
vehicles
that's not true it's just part of your
income and then you just have this
unusually large expense associated with
your job
which is uh gas maintenance and
replacement of a vehicle you destroy the
value of every two years
and so that's correct yeah you've got a
budget for that if you want to get a
it's not a bad idea to get a second car
but the reasoning for that is not that
they give you so much money because they
really don't give you so much money
after we factor in the loss in value on
whatever you're driving because whatever
you drive you destroy it value-wise
that's right
and so um yeah what i always tell road
warriors is that it's a business expense
and the goal with business expenses to
do the minimum
expense
thereby maximizing profits
and so the less we spend on car the more
money you have
and how do we how do we minimize the
damage done to your finances with you
being on the road all the time and so
my formula is you buy the least vehicle
least expensive vehicle that will get
the job done
in quotes now let me describe to you
what i think get the job done is in this
situation
if i spend
40 000 miles a year in a car it's gonna
have a it's going to be a decent car
that rides well i'm not doing that in a
in a you know a freaking dodge neon
okay because you'll be in the
chiropractor uh you gotta have something
that's a decent decent ride because
you're in the car all the time
okay so that's part of get the job done
the second part is it has to obviously
be reliable
but you don't take a 60 000 vehicle and
go destroy it
you take a 20 000 or 15 000 vehicle and
go destroy it
and then you figure out what you know
what that does and
uh um and every two years or every three
years however you want to do it i mean
120 000 miles 80 000 miles you've got to
roll that thing over and do it again but
you've lost every bit of the value
during the time you drove it
uh and that's just that's just part of
your reality and that's okay it's like
it's like you own a heat and air company
and you got four trucks on the in your
fleet going out and calling on houses
it's part of your cost of doing business
so but you want to limit that you don't
go buy a
you know 150 000 service truck if you're
in the heat and air business and if
you're smart anyway
and so that that's how i would do it and
now okay so now we got a 12 000 or a 15
000
whatever okay you call it whatever you
wanna call it i don't care it's got
reasonable gas mileage it's uh
reasonable comfort and is reliable now
do we spend some more money on something
that sits in the driveway most of the
time that is my quote real car
unquote that i don't plan on destroying
and if you want to do that either way
you're going to pay cash for both
and both of them are going to go down in
value but obviously the one on the road
is going to go down the most and the
fastest and that's how i look at being a
road warrior in that anything we've got
around here we do the same thing you're
amateurizing
the expense
uh you know another example in our world
is we buy we spend a lot of money on
computers around here
a thousand people and they've all got a
computer
and uh you know what that computer's
worth in two years
nothing oh boy
wow nothing
and dave is okay with that it doesn't
bother me
there's no problem
it's a door stop
after two years yeah it's like
something else comes out and the same
with this stuff you know i got what two
million bucks in a stinking studio you
know and all the wires and the
electronics and the spaceship it looks
like you're in there running nasa or
something
and
you know it's probably got a five year
shelf life
wow and uh so you just gotta look at
that and go okay
stinking stuff is gonna deteriorate the
electronics don't deteriorate but the
the stuff that they plug into on the
other end becomes obsolete might i make
a suggestion dave to see if you like it
i'm opening myself up here okay all
right so we're talking cash we gave this
man advice it's got to be cash
uh maybe he gets a uh maybe he gets a a
car that runs but it's an older car a
classic car and the value doesn't go
down he's on the road monday through
friday and when he's driving around on
the weekends it's easy i'm just saying
that he's in his karman ghia maybe
like yours yeah yeah that car is going
up in value each year it's nice and it
runs not bad i'm just saying that my
1960 corvette's actually going to go up
in value but there's very few things
that go up in value that have motors and
wheels yeah very few things and they
don't go up much no it's not like you're
going make no this isn't like real
estate and it's not got you know
neither one of those cars have the
creature comforts of the modern vehicle
yeah that's true there is no but it's
not a horrible idea is what i'm asking
not a badass i don't mind i'm saying hey
if you take that you can have a little
cool get around the weekend just
something fun to tool around then a
weekend ride yeah you know but it's not
your quote daily drive no yeah that's
not a bad idea but again you don't want
to spend 100 grand on that oh no you
can't have a lemon and this is you got
to be smart about this purchase yeah in
terms of i mean the purchase price
doesn't have to be that it's no
no no it's a it's a driver
it's not a museum piece so it's a
interesting world but yeah
the thing is you're going to lose the
money on